whoever it was that you were in love with.
It sounds more like her.
Her history. Do not bring me
knock it off!
of what ever knows
how black your eyes were.
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture. He.
He picked a pretty set.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie Marvel dropped a brand
new Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer.
There's a whole bunch of new footage and
Easter eggs, so we'll break it all down.
I know lots of theories
about how they're going to end the movie
because this is meant to be the last time
the Guardians of the Galaxy team
in this current form rides together.
Of course, I'll do videos
for all the other Super Bowl trailers.
They even dropped a second brand new flash
trailer with totally different footage.
I'll do a video for that too.
It'll take me the next couple of days.
Get through them all. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
I'm also allowed to post my Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania
review on Tuesday, so look out for that.
But the big thing in
this trailer is obviously the Guardians
going up against the high evolutionary.
He's meant to be the person
who created rocket like rockets.
Bad space Dad.
Most of the Guardians movies
revolve around bad space dads, Thanos
then Ego's Living Planet,
all terrible fathers now high evolutionary
couple,
big changes from his comic book backstory
that I'll explain
as we go through the trailer.
But the brand new songs
they play on this trailer
is Since You Been Gone By a Rainbow.
They actually used some rainbow
when they were promoting Thor
Love and Thunder.
Like a lot of classic rock
and roll songs in Marvel movies now.
But James
Gunn is using this song in particular
because it's a metaphor for the Guardians
being gone for so long. Like, we're back.
Finally, one last ride.
And because Gamora has been gone
for so long, like Peter
Quill is so bummed out
at the beginning of the trailer,
but charting
the timeline of Marvel movies,
just how long has it actually been?
It's only been a little while
since the events of Thor,
Love and Thunder,
and this is a marvel Phase
five movie Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania
takes place a little bit before it.
At the beginning of the trailer,
Rocket comes to talk to Peter Quill,
who's getting drunk on space booze.
Not really sure what the label says here.
There might be a couple of minor
Easter eggs in the background.
A lot of the T-shirts that Peter Quill
wears are also advertisements for space
candy like candy the James Gunn invented
to sell around the universe that he buys.
There's a quick montage of action scenes
from different parts of the movie,
the beginning, the end of the movie,
when everything goes crazy.
This scene of them slow walking together.
That was at the end of the first trailer.
It seems like
it's from the end of the movie.
It is in the high evolutionary space.
Maybe on Counter Earth.
It's hard to tell
where exactly his actual base is
because there are a couple locations
that they travel to in the movie.
He narrates a quick backstory for
the Guardians of the Galaxy in general,
because it's meant to be the final movie.
So he's like,
This is what we've done so far.
These are all the things
we've accomplished together.
And they have that joke
about what happened with Gamora.
Like now
she's a completely different person
because it's the Gamora from 2014
that came forward to the future
and then took off.
And the reason
why she seems like such an asshole to him,
why she doesn't care as much about him
is because she didn't experience
any of the things the original Gamora
did starting with the events
of the first Guardians movie,
and that was the movie where she started
to develop a relationship with him.
But when the movie picks up,
the whole idea
is that that version of Gamora took off
after Avengers Endgame.
There was a deleted scene
where you actually see her
literally walk off,
or they're all taking a knee
For Tony Stark,
like all the other Avengers everyone is
there is paying homage to him in
Gamora is like, Who the hell is Tony
Stark, who's Iron Man and just takes off?
And at some point after that, she took
over what remained of the Ravagers group.
And it has been kind of
like a softer version of Thanos
lording over the Ravagers
since then, like a more hardcore
version of the character,
all these scenes with their funny reunion
where he just knocking him around
seem like it's pretty early in the movie
after he finds out
that she's the new leader of the Ravagers.
I think the way they play it in the movie,
it's meant to be a big surprise for him.
Like, Wait, what is Gamora?
The person I've been looking
for this whole time?
When they're joking inside
this alien facility, it's hard to tell
what's happening
during this part of the movie
because it almost
seems like it's meant to mirror
them being in prison
during the first movie,
but they're wearing
orange jumpsuits instead,
and it might just be a research facility.
I don't know if they're actually prisoners
here.
The other funny Easter Egg for the first
movie is that he's holding the orb there
while they're talking about the events
of the first movie.
Remember in that first movie,
the Power stone was Inside an Orb.
So there's probably lots of references
to all the other Guardians
of the Galaxy movies
in all their other adventures.
This wooden looking Marvel Studios logo.
If you couldn't tell,
like the white version of it
is meant to be a reference to Peter
Quill's tape player from the first movie,
that ship wound up being destroyed.
But obviously,
like I said, they're referencing things
from that first movie
when they come up on this planet
and Peter Quill looks flabbergasted,
absolutely surprised.
It's meant to be Counter Earth.
So the whole idea with Counter Earth
is that in the comics, Herbert Windham
starts out as this normal scientist
and wants to perfect himself in winds up
becoming turning himself into the high
evolutionary through experiments.
His whole thing is that he wants to create
the perfect being, the perfect race,
and he feels like our version of Earth,
like the normal earth that he came from
isn't enough.
So he winds up
creating counter Earth as a sort of place
for him to experiment with that idea.
So the Avengers, other superpowered beings
couldn't just see it with the naked
eye, like, Wait a minute, there's
another planet that looks just like Earth.
What's going on here in on counter Earth?
His big thing was experimenting
with human animal hybrids,
which is where we get to the Adam Warlock
back story.
There's like a big intersection
with Adam Warlock in the high Evolutionary
because in the comics,
the high evolutionary
is the one that gave him the soul Stone.
Now he does
have a gem in his forehead in this movie,
but obviously it's not the soul stone
because Thanos atomized those.
But when they go to Counter Earth,
that's why it looks exactly like Earth,
like this creepy version of Earth
with a bunch of human animal hybrids.
A lot of these will probably be references
of the comic book
versions of the characters.
This actually looks like Rocket's actual
origin story.
Like kids are walking around this chamber
here in the center,
you see, like a version of Rocket
that's slowly
being experimented on so that he can talk
and he can walk on two legs.
This seems like the
Hi Revolutionaries home base.
Like a lot of the action scenes
take place here, a lot of the debris,
the big fight scenes that they have,
it's hard to tell if this is near
the giant space, but that they travel to
in the other trailer,
like there's this giant scene
that looks like a giant celestial size
space anus.
That's part of the joke of the Guardians
of the Galaxy movies
like you have a celestial head of Nowhere,
which they actually own now.
They bought that from the collector
during the Guardians of the Galaxy
Christmas special.
We had a celestial head.
There's a dead celestial sticking out
of the Indian Ocean on Earth currently.
Now we have a giant celestial asshole.
This is the first time
we've seen the high evolutionary
without his comic book armor on, like he's
wearing more casual clothing.
Here he looks a little bit different
from the comics.
Like he wears red armor in the comics
and he has a face plate.
But the reason why he wears that,
the reason why his face is covered in
the comics is because it's been so twisted
because of all his experiments.
You see him use his powers
a little bit later in the trail,
like he's floating down the hallway.
He has all kinds of powers in the comics.
It's one of those situations where
because he's trying to evolve himself,
thus the name High Evolutionary,
he continues to give himself
more and more powers over time,
making himself more powerful.
This is another version of Rocket's
origin story Tiny Baby Rocket
getting terrified the way
that James Gunn talks about the character.
He was totally happy to just exist
as a normal raccoon.
He did not want to be turned
into what he is now, even though he's done
all these great things.
He's had all these great adventures,
made all these great friends and family,
he's still really bitter about what
the high evolutionary he did to him
in Rocket's whole speech here,
I think is meant to be a metaphor for just
the general themes of the movie itself
when he says the high evolutionary didn't
want to make things perfect,
he just hated the way that things were.
The whole message is meant to be
You're perfect the way you are.
You don't need to change yourself
in the way
that all the movies have very broad themes
the knife and the number are references
to Rocket's experiment number,
like he was just referred
to as a number by evolutionary.
You actually see an Easter egg for that in
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie.
When they do the big lineup
and they show you his entire backstory.
The Half world Easter Egg is
where Rocket is from in the comics.
In the comics is back.
Story was completely different.
Maybe they'll have some Easter eggs
for half a world during this movie.
Couple of big action scenes,
especially with Nebula.
They show you that she's gotten
a couple of new weapons too.
Like she heats up
this blade that she shoots out of her arm.
This scene of them in the spacesuits,
everybody keeps asking about,
is this a reference to among us?
Because they look
kind of like the characters from among us?
Or is it a reference
to the colors of the infinity stones?
Because they're all the different colors
of the infinity stones.
What James Gunn actually revealed
is that all these different suits
are meant to be a reference
to 2001 Space Odyssey, like
they're not meant to be
in Among US reference,
and they're not a reference
to the Infinity stones,
this giant space anus that they're
traveling to either belong to a huge
creature or it is part of a celestial,
like a dead celestial high
evolutionary experimenting
on, which is an idea that I like
more, like the whole idea
that high evolutionary
would love to get his hands on more
celestial tech celestials are meant to be
the most powerful beings in the universe
next to other cosmic characters.
With a few exceptions,
there are a couple characters
that are a little bit
more powerful than the Celestials,
but not that many.
So characters like Kang, for instance,
have celestial symbols
on his technology and all the Ant-Man,
the WASP Quantumania trailers.
Of course,
Kang would also want to use Celestial tech
because it is the most advanced tech.
The high evolutionary would try to do
the same thing if he could.
These are just more scenes
of the Guardians of the Galaxy versus
the High Evolutionary and his home base.
Most of the big action scenes later in
the movie seem like they take place here.
We see Cragen wearing Yondu thin
and holding his arrow in front of him.
He's been slowly getting better
and better with the arrow over time.
Like when he first got it,
he was terrible.
Then he got a little bit better by the
Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday special.
I think the idea is that now
he can actually use it pretty decently.
Usually they use crackle in
for jokes though,
so they'll probably be some comedy behind
that Big reminder.
The crackling is also played by James
Gunn's real life brother,
who's also the stand in on set for Rocket.
Because Bradley Cooper
only does The Voice.
We get a very ominous voiceover from Drax,
where he makes it sound like he's
going to try and sacrifice himself.
I did a video recently
about how the logos reveal
who's going to die
at the end of the movie,
but it might be a fake out where Rocket
just tries to sacrifice himself.
And then Drax winds up saving him
and sacrificing himself because Dave
Bautista did say that this was going
to be his final Marvel movie ever.
When the high evolutionary
says Incinerate them
and he's wearing his casual clothing,
he's probably
talking about his other experiments,
like he might not be talking
about the Guardians of the Galaxy.
The whole idea is
they want to make it seem like
he doesn't care
about any of his creations,
like they are literally
just experiments to him.
We get a bunch of new Adam
warlock footage.
We see him
flying across a bunch of debris.
He has a bunch of comic book powers.
I don't know
how many of his comic book powers
they're going to give the movie version
of the character.
He is meant to be one of the most powerful
Marvel characters, though
James Gunn
also confirmed a lot of my theories
in that
they're playing the character
in this movie
a little bit, the way they played vision
in Avengers Age of Ultron, born yesterday.
Like all those kinds of jokes, like he's
basically a baby
who was just born, so he doesn't
really understand people that much.
And a lot of his arc in
the movie is meant to flow with the themes
of his original comic book origin story,
where he was originally created
to be a weapon and then slowly learns
over time to figure things out on his own
and kind of balances out.
Usually
when people think of the character,
they think of him
as being a good character.
But he's gone both ways.
And there's the whole major's personality.
I'm not expecting them
to do a whole lot of major stuff
in the Marvel movies, at least right now,
but they could always do that
in the future.
In the comics,
he was created by a separate group
on Earth,
but eventually he left them
and just traveled the galaxy, trying
to learn new things, just learning
about cultures, people, society.
Those travels took him to the high
evolutionary counter earth, where high
evolutionary formed a bargain
with him to help get rid of mad
bees, which was one of his human animal
hybrid creations that have gone crazy
in as part of that high evolutionary
upgraded him with the soul gem.
Also when Adam Warlock went to counter
Earth to try and deal with man bees,
the people that were living there
that he was trying to save
gave him the name Adam Initially
it was meant to be a biblical reference,
like the biblical Adam.
There's not a lot of religion
in Marvel movies,
so I don't know how they're going
to explain
the Adam Warlock in this movie,
but I think that they're just going
to have one of the Guardians characters
give him the name
Groot versus Adam Warlock.
This is a reunion scene
between Rocket and Lyla,
who was his girlfriend in the comics.
She's meant to be another one of the high
evolutionary experiments just like him.
Really cool scene of Groot,
hooking out with Star-Lord, going crazy.
The high Evolutionary is based.
I don't know if he's going to get
any bigger, like any taller, so to speak.
James going to explain.
He's meant to be kind of
like the son of the original groups.
Like the Original Groot isn't coming back.
This isn't meant to be like him
being reborn into a new body.
This group is meant to have a completely
different personality from the Groot
in the first Guardians movie.
Also kind of seems like he's
addicted to video games.
Really?
Like the classic Game Boy
Easter Egg in the holiday special
to Speaking of which, it'll be funny
to see if they address rocket
having winter soldiers arm
because Sebastian Stan also talked
about that in real life he's like
well I guess winter soldier's probably
going to get a new arm at some point.
That might be him giving away a spoiler
for the Thunderbolts movie.
They might actually give him a totally
different arm, but I'm not expecting it.
There's a little bit of Cosmo footage.
He was featured during the Guardians
of Galaxy Holiday Special
because he's a much bigger character
during the movie.
She was in.
The first Guardians movie is an Easter
egg, but only briefly in the comics.
She's based on Laika,
the Russian space dog,
but in the Marvel Universe,
she was shot into space
by the Russians as an experiment
and then went up traveling to nowhere
and got bombarded with these cosmic rays
that gave her the special abilities
that she has.
The reason why she can talk
isn't because she can move her lips.
She basically beams her thoughts
into other people's heads telepathically.
What I refuse to do any more work
while you do mean.
All right, all right. I'm sorry.
It seems like they want to show
Star-Lord slowly winning more over.
I don't know if that's going to happen
by the end of the movie
because I don't think
either one of them are going to die.
The new buzzy character beneath them that
they're protecting is just named Blurb.
He's meant to be like Rocket, like one of
the other high evolutionary experiments,
this thing of rocket
fighting on top of Groot shoulder
obviously meant to be a reference
to them doing the exact same thing
in the first Guardians movie
Drax versus Adam Warlock using two energy
swords or two energy weapons.
He might have one of atom warlocks.
Weapons like these might be two of his
weapons, and Drax just stole one of them.
If Drax is going to die in this movie,
I would not be surprised if Adam Warlock
winds up being the one to kill him,
but it always could be something else
at the end of the movie,
because I think part
of the arc of that film
is that Adam
more like fights them in the beginning,
and then like in the comics,
he slowly starts to figure out
that they're not so terrible in
Why is it helping them by the end?
And I said, This is my video
for the last big trailer for the movie.
But the Guardians are wearing their comic
book, accurate Guardians
of the Galaxy uniforms, too,
from the Annihilation Conquest run
where Adam Warlock actually wound up
joining the Guardians of the Galaxy team.
So it is always possible
that at the end of the movie, or like
in the next Guardians of the Galaxy
Adventure, Adam Warlock is on that roster.
There's a big montage of them
just going out in Blaze of Glory
all over the place.
Like they want to make you wonder
if anybody is going to make out of this
film alive, but I genuinely think
only like one or two characters
are actually going to die this funny.
You're seeing them
slow walking with Nebula holding.
Peter Quill is actually on nowhere,
remember?
They own that as of the Guardians
of the Galaxy Holiday special.
Then it's funny.
Tag scene at the end of the trailer
with Gilmore
and Nebula is meant to be a mirror
for Thor and Star-Lord.
During Thor, Love and Thunder,
where Thor started to lean in
and Star-Lord was like,
No, dude, I'm not talking about me.
Stop doing that. That's weird.
Me What?
Just listening nugget off.
What ever noticed
how black your eyes were?
Where Star-Lord does
basically the same thing with Nebula?
Like Gamora was joking
that he's more in love with her
and he kind of thinks about it
for a minute, like,
Wait a minute,
maybe I am in love with Nebula.
I never thought about it that way.
The funny thing about Nebula
that James Gunn revealed
is that when they were making
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie
and Karen Gillan was kind
of developing the Nebula character,
like the way she speaks, the way she acts,
they were having trouble
finding something that they really liked.
So James Gunn had her perform
the character as if she was kind of like
a sassy version of Marilyn Monroe,
which is something that you cannot unsee.
Anytime you hear
Nebula speak now, you just hear Marilyn
Monroe's voice like a slightly stabby
version of Marilyn Monroe.
I don't worry about me.
I'm only concerned about you two.
It's a wonderful moon. Not tonight.
Thanks, Dad.
Sounds fair.
This is one fight you will win.
The big thing, though, is that
even though this is meant to be
the last Guardians of the Galaxy movie
with this particular roster, that doesn't
mean it'll be the last Guardians
movie ever or the last time
you see the Guardians of the Galaxy
in any of the movies.
For instance, Sylvester Stallone's
Starhawk character,
who's on that original Guardians
team, like the Guardians 3000 team,
he's also supposed to be in the movie.
I don't know how many of the other
classic guardians are in there too,
but it's one of those ideas that you see
these space teams
pop up in different space movies
all the time.
I don't know if there's going to be
any kind of references to the Guardians
in the Marvel's movie
because that'll be taking place a lot.
Increased role space,
I think, or at least reference
a lot of what's happening
in that part of space.
And there are talks about them doing
a Nova Disney Plus series or a
one off special presentation, kind of like
they did for Werewolf by Night.
That would be much more connected
to the Guardians mythology
because they very literally
spent a lot of time with the Nova Core.
But the whole idea is that after
the movie comes out,
James Gunn is officially
like permanently moving over to DC
and not really going to be involved
with any future Marvel productions.
As far as I know,
he's kind of half and half right now.
Like he just released
his big reboot trailer.
I've already done a couple of videos for
that, so already in the comments below.
But like I said, bunch of other big
Super Bowl trailers just release.
I'll do videos for everything.
It probably take me a couple days
to get everything out.
They also release
like a second additional flash trailer
with even more brand new footage.
So I'll do a video for that as well.
You can click here for that
brand new flash
Super Bowl trailer video,
a whole bunch of Easter eggs.
And click here for all my other
Super Bowl trailers already the link
as soon as I post those.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.